et du bal du lycée qu'on parle ça
n'arrive qu'une fois et je veux pas
manquer ça comme nous tous ouais non
c'est clair il faut que vous y alliez
sans moi il y a aucune raison pour que
ma mère me gâche la vie et gâche aussi
la vôtre
bah sinon tu fais le mur quoi
ça t'en parle pas à ta mère c'est tout
ce serait menti je vote pour c'est bon
Ruby dit oui dit oui je voudrais bien
mais si ma mère l'apprend rubis enfin on
a qu'une vie là faut vraiment que tu
passes à la vitesse supérieure et que tu
viennes oh bal ok ok ok ok ok
vous avez raison ok je vais faire ça je
vais aller au bal ouais biologie marine
trimestrielle oh Ruby tu lis encore ses
bêtises les humains ne savent pas tout
sur l'océan maman il y a tout un monde
que j'ai jamais vu sous la surface les
méduses le plancton les récifs de
corails monstrueuses et ces monstres
nouvelles du mal à nous les Kraken ici
c'est un refuge au Sunside c'est chez
nous alors laisse-moi aller au bal c'est
comme ça que je vais m'intégrer Ruby la
réponse est non
allez c'est l'heure
de passer à Guilman
on se redresse on va passer une bonne
journée humaine ça vous gêne pas vous
qu'on monte à tout le monde comme ça
tout le temps c'est pas du mensonge
juste une légère omission ouais ok
souvenez-vous si on nous pose la
question on vient du Canada